- Can I tell you this really quick?
- Yes.
- It was early 2000's,
and I had been doing my
plays for a long time
and I got a chance to do
one here for the first time,
everybody's saying you
have to do it in L.A.,
you have to do it in L.A.
So I do it at the Wilshire Ebell Theater.
Everybody shows up, all the agents show up
and it was a big moment for me.
They had offers for me to do things
and that'd never happened for me before.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So I'm driving home and I'm in tears.
I'm so grateful, so thankful to God
and I hear your song for the first time,
"A Moment Like This."
- Oh.
- Yes.
And that thing tore me
up so I'm trying to drive
and crying it's a moment like
this I've been waiting for.
So, thank you.
- It tore me up to, I cried to.
- Thank you for that, yeah.
Thank you for that.
- Oh my gosh, that's so funny
that you don't know each other
and then years later
we run into each other.
That's such a, life is so
beautiful I love that about life.
You never know what is
going to affect you,
the domino effect it
will have, it's so cool.